all right Britain's newest royal is
being put to the test today Prince
Harry's wife Megan join Queen Elizabeth
today for her first royal engagement
without her husband the Queen and the
former actress rode the Royal train to
the city of Chester in northwest England
for a busy day of events Roxana Saberi
is there Roxana good morning good
morning the crowds behind me gave Queen
Elizabeth and Megan Markel a warm
welcome as they made their way to a
local town hall just a few steps from
here where they're now having lunch they
arrived by Royal train at a local
station earlier this morning understood
that you traveled together overnight
less than a month on the new job Megan
is still getting the hang of royal
protocol leaving the station there
appear to be a bit of confusion over who
should get in the car first but from
then on things went more smoothly
already this morning megan has overseen
the official opening of her first bridge
in her first theatres something the
Queen has done countless times over the
years though this is Megan's first
engagement without Prince Harry she does
have the Queen by her side giving her
the Royal Seal of Approval and showing
once again that the Duchess of Sussex is
being welcomed to the royal family gale
she's already very popular Thank You
Roxana Saberi reporting from Chester
England